question qu'est ce qui sort tous les
jours à 6 heures pour vous présenter une
vidéo en parlant d'un truc est plutôt
cool comme dans le calendrier de l'avent
parce que sa garde les nerfs en 24 jours
oui cette chaîne youtube et vous avez
répondu à cette énigme c'est pourquoi
aujourd'hui je veux vous parler
d'énigmes avoue piaffer d internet
j'ai sélectionné deux boîtes de coffrets
qui sont sortis chez larousse les deux
je crois oui c'est ça nana qui s'appelle
casse-tête inferno ses 60 des filles
100% machiavélique
alors après arrêter de dire que nous on
fait du pit à cliquer un surtout le jeu
et des titres publics soirée et dim 254
être machiavélique également pour animer
vos soirées
alors je suis pas certain qu'on anime
une soirée avec ça celui-ci la boîte un
petit peu abîmés
si vous avez l'oeil vous voyez que ça
fait partie d'une gamme que je connais
bien ce style de boîte avec 250 cartes à
l'intérieur mais on dirait bien que
c'est la même chose que mon jeu ouais
c'est dans la même série que le jeu
menteur menteur que j'ai sorti que vous
trouvez aussi dans la description donc
très classique il ya des styles
d'énigmes et vous avez les ming de sur
la carte et vous avez un livret avec
toutes les réponses des énigmes il est
sympa pour celui qui aime ça il y a pas
d'énigme trop surprenante mais il est
très sympa à quelqu'un qui aimeraient en
fait commencé à se mettre aux énigmes
c'est tout à fait le genre de coffrets
que vous pouvez lui offrir
par contre lui si c'est vous qui aimez
les énigmes fortement je ne trouvais
vraiment cool l'impression d'être un
vieux cancrelats avec sa boule parce
qu'il décompose des cartes en énigmes
différente avec expérience du diabolique
avec des tests de logique mais surtout
ce que j'aimais dans cette boîte
c'est énormément denim qui prennent le
principe de la tour de hanoi
connaissez-vous la tour de hanoi non on
peut écouter juste expliqué madame
chabaud latour de hanoi
c'est un principe de cercle qui sont
fournis genre ces exactions des enfants
ni les cercles oui mais pas toujours
tout est fourni des cercles de
différentes tailles qu'on va empiler la
tornade la plus simple c'est celle ci
est l'idée par exemple cette belgique et
une position ici initie et initie
et on doit reconstituer la pile ici avec
deux contraintes la contrainte une de la
torre de hanoi c'est qu'on peut délivrer
à ses les pièces fine par une est
articulée en option et la contrainte
numéro deux de la torre de la nice et
que une pièce ne peut jamais être posée
sur une pièce plus petite qu'elle a
toujours être dans un ordre décroissant
la plus grosse en bas et la plus petite
au dessus donc si par exemple on voulait
se déplacer là on ferait quelque chose
un petit peu comme ça si on imagine
qu'ils avaient trois positions et on
aurait déplacé toute la tour de hanoi en
respectant les deux contraintes et bien
là il ya plus de ces acquis y en a six
et il ya beaucoup d'énigmes dessus c'est
la première fois que je découvre en fait
une boîte d'énigmes qui a poussé le
concept de la tour de hanoi autant avec
autant de choses différentes et moi qui
aime bien ça et bien pour la première
fois j'ai pu m'éclater
les tests diabolique et les tests de
logique à l'intérieur sont assez
chouette aussi avec des choses très
légère comme celui ci qui a vraiment
juste un test de mise en perspective
mentale et ça j'aime bien vous c'est
pour faire travailler la visualisation
il a logiquement talent là c'est un
système de cercles et de poulies et on
doit juste en connaissant le sens de
rotation de la première déterminer le
sens de rotation de la dernière dans une
ancienne vidéo que vous voyez apparaître
juste là où vous avez parlé de tesla et
de sa capacité à visualiser des choses
et comment vous pouviez vous aussi
visualiser en 3d dans votre esprit eh
bien ça ça participantes plus à
l'entraînement donc c'est assez chouette
et ça fonctionne comme des flashs garde
les réponses sont toujours derrière
voilà j'ai adoré cette boîte
j'ai bien aimé celle ci met vraiment
elle s'adresse plus à ceux qui veulent
un grand stock d'énigmes six mètres ou
avoir un petit jeu comme ça à faire à
l'apéro avec les copains mais ça c'est
plus cool alors c'est fait pour jouer à
plusieurs
mais messi si vous êtes comme moi que
vous aimez sable pour soi tout seul
c'est très bien et les deux sont au prix
ça sert et à 9 euros celle ci allait à
10,095 voilà j'espère que ça vous a plu
merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo que vous pouvez louer comme des
guides vous retrouverez les références
de la description non ce n'est pas un
placement produit qui serait par exemple
la pression de produits c'est de vous
rappeler que dans la description il ya
également mais place pour l'olympia vous
pouvez trouver ça vous pouvez choisir
votre siège auto
c'est le bon cardinaux elle vous pouvez
vous abonner à l'achat ne s'est pas
encore fait rendez vous demain à 6
heures shao
[Musique]